dude directed by burt and birdie who are
you that is so much more of the show
that's so much more of the show i've
been waiting for
wow that was great that was amazing from
beginning to freaking end that was great
what's going on bro and bro and bro and
bro the bros are back to watch hawkeye
episode three bro it is called echoes
which i am very much excited about that
turtle baby yeah yeah we have koi janjo
joining us today you're gonna want to
stick around after the reaction because
these are comic book experts so you can
point out some stuff and you know what i
want to say something some people think
we're spoiling stuff sometimes naming
characters
their names are and here they are yeah
so we haven't seen the rest of the shows
we don't have that pertain to this we
know the story arcs
got her own show
spoiler alert she makes it i assume i
feel like all we've pointed out are like
what pops up for fans of the comic to go
ooh reference like also they're totally
different than the comic like the comic
is not being followed this is the
character this is not like the comic in
way more ways than it is like the comics
posters are more like the comic that the
show is like the comic all right guys
well hit that like button subscribe and
click that notification bell with watch
along is where you sync up with us to
watch hawkeye or over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows over
there as well and thanks to the boys
over at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights let's check out this
episode very much excited for it
[Music]
we have
them
echo
[Laughter]
as fast as a dragon
oh
it's quiet thank you
watch chongqi you'll know
multiples funny you should ask
no
maybe they are
but dragons
live in a different world the marvel
cinematic
you
have to learn
to jump between two worlds
just by watching
yo this is [ __ ] great
it's acting oh man
i'm so into this
all right class water break
be good in class today
is she about to be the task master we
wanted
uncle will take you home after class
i'll see you tonight
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh man ready
[Music]
that's gotta have been that who we think
it is
man auto repair
kevin smith easter egg
oh
no
oh [ __ ] ronin
is this our first blood splatter in the
mcu oh maybe maybe
wow
oh no
no
no
wow
no
ronin did that
oh
there you go wow
that's really in love with them this
show is a different show
anymore
you good
i buy
imagine dragons tickets for my
[Laughter]
said that the girlfriend were gift so
she wants to bring her sister
i mean look on the bright side you don't
have to go see imaginarians
what kid
yeah
be hating kate she doesn't even like
them no she did this
look i think you both owe apologies
tell her she hurt you
[Laughter]
i need to just okay okay see you
see a little trust
[Laughter]
connection
you rely too much on technology
well my go-to weapon is two sticks
string so
no she needs your hearing aid oh you
might find you're better off without it
yeah sometimes i think the very same
thing
now the suit
she put it on by accident
she didn't know what it means
she's not ruining
look at her she's nine
and just because she's not the ronin
doesn't mean that ronan's not back
because he's dead
so who got him
[Music]
[Music]
that's then the time to be scared we're
gonna get out of this you'll go back to
living your life i'll go back to my
family you gotta harness that
overconfidence of yours okay it's
ridiculous
they're in a kb toys
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
damn
oh
cold move
nice man
yes
[Music]
there's that greatest archer in the
world
oh
sweet
that's cool
yeah
wow actually so much more improved
see that is called noticing a comic
reference
yeah
not a spoiler
come over here
oh that car is going to come back
i'm not hearing you you dry
oh no
yes christmas music
oh
nice oh [ __ ] have we entered a water
yes oh we're doing it oh my god
beautiful one
i have such big nipple chills right now
a christmas warner
oh please go hardcore henry right now
just
wait wait wait
we're out of regular arrows
oh my god
[Music]
whoever directs this episode needs more
wow i love the perspective forget a wide
angle lens on that thing
what what is that arrow
[Music]
they were communicating
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
can't stop christmas
come on kate
okay
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
oh you wrecked the car oh
challenger gets totaled anyway
you did read the comic
[Laughter]
i know
[Music]
she's a future marvel hero
this moment inspired it take out that
truck aim high bring the arrow down
[Laughter]
how cool
[Music]
hell yeah hell yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
suction cup arrow with purpose
yes
[Music]
and then you later's riding the train
kingpin's driving
what a perfect episode tv
[Music]
yes
oh my god you really think so
i'm gonna lie i i wasn't sure how i'd do
it i just wash a dog
[Laughter]
cooped up all day
hopefully that avengers health plan
covers a replacement hearing aid
[Music]
the way this episode has handled the
shifting in and out of the hearing
incredible really well done
daniel nathaniel what are you doing
buddy
is everything okay where's mama
it would help if you just text kate type
the kid might be able to text no for
kate
hey buddy it's kind of a bad connection
you're oh you're bored
you're the early birdie but i miss you
you know i'm gonna be there like i said
right
um i'm so happy to hear your voice
oh jesus
[Music]
this feels like that you know hot guy
coming
it's that one shot
[Laughter]
you need a more recognizable costume uh
does it come in purple
[Laughter]
my job for the last 20 years
was to be not recognizable right well
you've officially failed at that picture
this
yes
yes
it's a nature that's on your forehead
that's
for hawkeye
well not happening
it was all black all black with a mask
maybe a hood
i don't feel let you keep the haircut
from a few years ago
the tracksuits have connected us both to
ronin and it's pretty clear they're not
just gonna drop this
well that
you are not wrong about not to mention
the fact that my mom might be marrying a
murderer
and then there's that
[Laughter]
little caesar
dogfighter
sir dog of pizza
pizza
there's too many coincidences he was at
the auction that night and yesterday he
offered me a butterscotch
not exactly a crime and when i tried to
stab him in the face to prove he was
lying he parried like a pro you tried to
step your mom's fiance in the face
so from the home network we should be
able to get past the encryption of my
mom's password
yeah i'm in the wrong business
[Laughter]
get into private security
don't move
directed by burt and birdie who are you
damn that was uh wow oh man that is so
much more of the show
that's so much more of the show i've
been waiting for
wow that was great that was amazing
from beginning to freaking end that was
great action writing directing suspense
actually caring about everyone that's
one of my favorite episodes of the
marvel shows period and it's also the
biggest leap from
anything to to up because loki for me
stayed exceptional one division was like
started strong and kind of dipped for me
falcon winter soldiers stayed good but
this was like i was in it was good but
this was like one of my favorite
episodes this was so human
and so funny and the action was so
unique and interesting and the fight
choreography was on par with anything
i've seen elsewhere but you're more
invested in the characters because they
let them breathe and the theme of
fatherhood complementing all the
storylines and like the holiday doesn't
feel like a gimmick and all the
cheesiness of the arrows like all the
fun of hawkeye in the comic books used
for
actually authentic laughs like they were
able to manipulate the like our us as an
audience that whole echo origin had grit
i think here that guy who played her dad
oh my god that's gotta be their kids i
mean guys kingpin showed up in the
inside it's gotta be kingpin that
happens
to us again yeah hold on let's see if
there's a post credit scene all i guess
not i was ready for kingpin maybe shows
up wow
we
are only theorizing that that's we have
no way we don't know
no further information that it it could
be though i mean like the way it was the
way they don't fit his voice they don't
show him also his voice was dinofrio
esque
i don't know
i want me to hear it back again i think
it like it was guys it was mahershala
they're building them up
it's the point of phase four it sounded
like it could have yeah i mean the way
they framed it the suit that it just i
mean because the size the guys bigger
like the the boss above that big dude
the boss above echo too that's like very
limited list in the comic it's kingpin
who actually killed echo's dad right yes
so i can't believe ronan like what's the
great way to utilize ronan's this is
what i mean there they like took an
element from the comic like echo's dad
dies
but it's gonna be ronan who doesn't make
it more personal and we are invested in
five minutes in that league yeah so
we're we're like wait hawkeye done
[ __ ] so that's what i mean by how
that casts doubt to me of maybe it's not
kingpin because they change it
there's a lot that that that seems like
they're eluding that's kingpin but damn
that was that was nuts that was like a
perfect episode television too like it
had a 3x structure it really escalated
everything it was contained to itself
where it feels like tv not like just a
piece of them yeah it gives us new
characters while building on other ones
that gave us a new villain like that was
perfect when they're talking about the
boss or uncle that could be kingpin
they're talking i really hope at some
point he says aw car it's the only thing
i was missing is i want to hear my car
we'll just talk a little bit more
especially from what we talked about
during the credits john i mean coin i
would just
wouldn't shut up during the crash
why don't you take it away yeah you kick
it off i mean i don't know if i'm gonna
say anything fresh from what you guys
said yeah this was what i was hoping for
since the promise of the show at all
this was
everything i wanted in terms of
emotional depth in terms of cool action
that i could actually see that wasn't
hidden by editing and you know a
mounting of this team up between kate
and clint and you know finally cresting
into what some of the bigger
implications are gonna be like it still
seems like we're at the outset of the
actual task at hand we gotta find out
who's above the tracksuit mafia but this
uh was really operating and firing on
all cylinders for me it had every layer
i hoped it could and it felt very
personal and it felt like yeah we're
deconstructing or at least peering into
the life of somebody who's lived this
fantastical role in front of us uh so
yeah this was a really the sort of
caliber i'd been hoping for since the
start yeah it's very intimate very human
i i think uh maya
the echo character we still haven't
gotten to see much of like the the super
set powers you know like we saw the
martial arts skills a lot um but in
terms of a character
what i loved is
is that actually that actually is she's
definitely real life i i don't know if
she's she is and she's a first nation as
well like that's that's the character
there was so much rage that she had to
portray and hurt
and angst and it's such a fascinating
character to watch because she can't
vocalize it she can't let it auditory
wise like let it out so she just has
it's all coming through eyes and body
language
and wow was she powerful i thought she
was excellent like for a for like a
prologue
echo origin tale it got me excited for
the fact she's gonna have her own show
and i was like all right i agree maybe
this opening bit will just be like maybe
this is the gritty part but the rest
let's see if it me because i know a lot
of people i feel like the general
response is a lot of people have liked
the first two episodes way more than how
we received it
but this sent it to like a whole new
calendar this was the show i've i've
been wanting this felt like i was
reading the reviews i read on yeah this
felt like the show that i read and i was
like wait did you see the same show and
that's no disrespect i just like arts
interpretive and i was reading it going
man i wish i felt this i wish i
connected this way this episode to me
was the biggest lift from two episodes
of tv to the third i've ever had i've
never felt so like casually invested and
i love hawkeye i love love love what
writers done with the character and i
would argue kate bishop's introduction
is one of the strongest in the mcu but
everything else never quite landed for
me so this to me was okay i've already
invested in those things i know and love
now you're giving me the action that
i've been promised now you're giving me
the buddy cop dude i've been promised
now you're giving me some eye lines and
some perspectives and an action shot
that is beautifully covered beautifully
lit i didn't expect and then you give me
a pen tech arrow then you go and bring
me to the the nerdiest weirdest mcu
hawkeye in the comic books is somewhat
of a punchline at times because he's a
guy with a bow and arrow they did a
great job in age of ultron really
establishing that tone this
leaps off of that and gives us a
combination of matt fraction hawkeye the
punchline hawkeye but the depth of
academy award winner jamie renner from
hurt locker this is everything well that
they did with the arrow was a callback
and uh is like mirroring with the civil
war moment yeah when ant-man is on top
of the arrow and now he just got a pin
marrow himself yeah that's gonna be a
comic book there's a comic book where
he's launching three pentax that's
amazing
that is straight from the comic books
that's amazing well it's funny you
should bring up that age of ultron
moment because kevin feige was just in
the trade saying basically that that
scene where he you know bolsters wanda's
confidence and says like hey there's
aliens and wizards and i'm just a dude
with a bow and arrow none of this makes
any sense he said like that was the
moment i knew hawkeye should have a show
and i feel like that really does kind of
resonate you know this is the episode
that makes me on a west coast avengers
show because i've wanted a young
avengers show i think it's coming i've
wanted a new avengers show i think it's
coming but this to me makes me want a
west coast avengers strangeness as well
simultaneously like we could have very
easily three avengers properties at once
uh you're saying west coast managers
yeah all the avengers can happen
simultaneously and they're setting it up
so all of them could be their own
structured teams and it would co-exist
beautifully absolutely i think what
they've done with like i love the diner
scene like the just the scene work
that's what i think really hit for me
this time around like this the overall
scene work from beginning to end i like
what they've done here with retconning
i mean maybe there isn't a version of
the comp but not what i read with kazi
and echo are they leaked like that in
the comments i don't recall that one
and the fraction run at least no and
also it's interesting is that maya is
ronan in arks okay maya is the one that
dresses as rhone and there isn't any uh
this isn't a spoiler because it's
different
kingpin has nothing to do with her
father's death in
this continuity seemingly but in the
comic books he does and this
ronin seems to be very directly due to
the father's death but she is dressed up
as ronan when hawkeye wants to prove
that he's not roman so there's a lot
that isn't coming from the comics which
gives us people that read the comics a
new exciting twist and turns well i
think it's a bold ass move to make
your like to have this intro with maya
you sympathize so much for her like just
from the very beginning when she's in
class and you're watching her struggles
mirroring her comic book the father and
daughter relationship that she has was
so beautiful in that bedroom scene i was
getting teary-eyed off of this
introduction moment with them just this
compassionate father who as you learn
has like some criminal dealings but in
terms of his relationship with his
daughter super compassionate super
caring and then to have
ronin excuse me from maya's perspective
not knowing who ronan is ronan killing
him off putting you in her shoes seeing
ronan as the villain and then cutting
the clinton yeah
so this whole episode is about fathers
and absolute fathers and present fathers
and father hood and all those things and
the whole time we're we're feeling all
these draws towards parenthood and then
it ends with the new father figure in
kate's life with a
nice a ronan's knife sword obviously uh
to the new father figure yeah i thought
that's why i thought the mirroring was
so cool because you have that opening
scene with maya and her father where
she's deaf she can't hear and then you
know the father's talking to her and
then to go to clint when that scene was
breaking my [ __ ] heart when he's
talking with his boy over the phone and
he's oh like you could see how
heartbroken he was how he couldn't come
home for christmas and he said some line
in there i don't recall verbatim like
it's good i'm just happy to hear your
voice again you could see how that was
choking him up so much so you got this
really great mirroring of perspectives
there from her origin story to what
clint is currently dealing with as well
i just think this is really strong solid
stuff from beginning to end i think
that's the most beautiful thing they did
this whole episode because him not being
able to hear and him taking his hearing
aid out intentionally part of the time
and also half the time having it just
being broken i feel like that's
something that they used for humor here
that they could have just used for humor
or some funny casual misunderstanding
they really made that a
character thread throughout this episode
and even especially in the moments where
he's got the hearing aid out just
because he doesn't want to hear what
kate's talking about or what's going on
around him like that was a subtle way of
completely body language oriented
pulling you into that into just clint
yeah and being intimate with clint and i
thought they used that in a really
interesting way also the the medium to
extreme close-ups on that diner scene
like they were
just right centered
and very wide lenses and i would argue
that you need you know this caliber of
two oscar winners like both of these
actors have won oscars and you need that
if you're gonna have this shot at a
diner conversation scene and this show
is i mean this this was a leap for me in
quality i can't quite like extrapolate
on it's insane and i this is a bit of
the uh you know the internet i'm ready
for your comments i love and appreciate
the hell out of the fact that this is a
show that's leaning into representation
to the level it is they actually cast
first nation people to play first nation
folk they actually cast someone deaf to
play someone deaf in that not only is it
adding to the performance like greg was
saying and all the things we felt from
the top but it also is in a world of
thousands upon hundreds of thousands of
actors these actors might not have
gotten the chance to be in a show like
this if they weren't focused on making
sure it was so authentic i don't know uh
i don't know that gentleman that played
the father and i might not have gotten
exposed to that incredible work if they
were just like ah cast anybody but since
they made sure it was authentic i feel
like that narrowed the pool down because
we did a lot of killing of those people
to make sure that that this actor got
his time to shine and i just want to say
like i appreciate marvel introducing me
to this actor i appreciate marvel giving
me maya as well in her own show because
that's something that we're working
towards with tv and film and all those
things and i think i saw it more in this
episode that i have in most in that it
introduced me to actors i've never been
exposed to and i'm so appreciative yeah
yeah whatever uh you know what i'm
trying to show okay
let me just no i i think like i i think
it is used very well and it's it feels
it feels great as someone who is ethnic
myself to see something where it's not
like making it about that you know
was it like shoehorned it just felt like
it was really important to the story
yeah well it's honoring the background
of the actors that they're actually
casting and it does bring natural
diversity instead of like look at our
diversity yeah
yeah i think i think that's awesome
isn't it haley steinfeld like a wide mix
of a bunch of ethnicities herself too
yeah she's got some filipino in there
pinoy pride baby she's got a little phil
but not a lot i mean i don't know i've
known that that's the that's the
best-looking part
in my eyes
i mean going back to that diner scene
though i i do love that moment because
you really see the differences there
between where they're at in their lives
yeah like kate
what's what's interesting to me about
that particular moment and and i i
actually felt like that was the most
reflective of the comic of of the matt
fraction run specifically of
clint feeling ashamed not exactly
feeling like he's a role model all these
things where he just kind of has this
negative outlook on himself
and kate being the one like no you're
actually great you're actually a really
awesome dude and you were the father
figure i sort of idolized i dreamt up in
my own mind of you being my father
figure yeah from the experience i had
when i was younger and you do inspire
you are a role model you're my role
model
and but at the same time you know that
scene starts off where she's talking
and clint is uh has his earpiece out and
he like he just doesn't want to listen
to any of this right he's so emotionally
detached at this point in his life but
then also i i also felt like the one of
the interesting dichotomies of that
scene is how they're both not really
listening to each other on what they're
actually really saying because sh she's
not taking a second to really understand
where he's coming from and when he's
trying to be like you don't understand
it's not all glory like on this this
takes a toll on you this this wears you
down this this is heartbreak this is
heart-wrenching stuff and she's like no
but we gotta get you a costume yeah you
gotta be awesome because you are awesome
and you know i love you
yeah just talks at him yeah that's what
i mean they don't listen to each other
and that's it that's so both the
characters and the fraction running that
you're speaking to and i also love like
we're communicating like the scene yeah
that builds to that scene like the to me
the car scene was so the comic book
obviously but it really started to build
the dynamic that i wanted earlier and
obviously you need to build to that but
i really feel like if the show stays
episode three quality then this is gonna
put it right up there with loki for me
at the top this was incredible i was
surprised by how like it took a jump
for our our perspectives at least maybe
you'll disagree and that's okay it's
everyone's least favorite episode
jumping off
like
when they cut first just the opening
scene like the tone of it was so much
more mature right away and then to get
to the ronin scene you got blood
splatter and people being cut up like it
was more it was more violently
provocative than the ronin scene in end
game i'm not sure we've seen blood
splatter i even asked when we were
watching it i was like i don't think
we've seen splattering blood in the mcu
before like the stabs and stuff like
literally the way the swords are
penetrating these people and the way
they moved that felt so much more we're
now approaching we're not daredevil
hallway we're approaching that insane
this action isn't cutting too much to
cut away we're living in it we're with
it uh now we start with the elephant in
the room and of course that elephant's
named wilson
i think oh from castle
elephant volleyball in the room
i think i think kingpin is is here no
it's definitely kingpin guys
i don't know sorry for spoiling the show
for you
i'm going to be the one guy who says
it's not him
it's it's merely a theory at this point
it's not like i was saying it's not like
mephisto where it was we all we all got
so cooked up we thought it was mephisto
they didn't show like a red poof of
smoke this is a giant man in a black
suit with a vincent d'onofrio s giggle
and and
it framed out to be spider-verse like
come on and you have that scene where
they're walking in the park and it
sounds like
uh clint has encountered him before
clint was saying to i'm not pulling him
from congress or something it just
sounds like history is that that clint
was saying that no there's a different
guy at the top some of you don't want to
meet somebody don't want to mess with
sounds like he's talking about coin
about uh wilson you know well yeah and
the way that whole moment is captured is
it's it's a visual tease the whole
language of that and just showing the
hand in a slight chuckle and then yeah
alluding to who's there's at least one
person above my
like yeah it seems like a very
deliberate thing rather than a bunch of
stray details that were all extrapolated
and if this is the mcu's version of
exploring organized crime and they've
been pulling that word
in this show
who's at the top of organized crime in
marvel what a great way to go from we
were talking the first two episodes
about how like we didn't really feel the
villain pull and if all of a sudden this
episode was like oh my god we love maya
oh my god whatever we've got like it
erased all of my concerns in an episode
it's just why did she what did ronan
kill
this is this is what i'm loving about
the experience with this episode is i'm
so caught up in what this show actually
gave us and not what the future is um
like why did he kill ronin well why did
ronan kill the maya his dad i assume he
was just because he was part of the
tracksuit mafia in that moment yeah i
mean he was in a tracksuit well he
seemed to have a position of power
within the organization i mean he was
working under kingpin if we're going off
the kingdom theory the guy was like your
uncle he's clearly very tied into that
family i mean it looked like if you i
don't know i mean my take on this might
be off but you know if you look at the
just the progression through the
physical space it looks like he was
killed in some kind of control area
what's that's what i love about this is
you the whole time you saw the dad you
never saw him through the eyes of clint
you only saw through the eyes of maya
which was this sweet
he put the crew before himself always
what yeah clint's got all that baggage
about who he killed and how many killed
and this is a great way to show that
without really having to go back in time
like we get to experience the trauma of
killing without having to see all the
stuff from end game i did not realize
that no one knew ronan was actually
clint barton i didn't realize there's
two secret identities in the mcu one
spider-man and one's coming out and
that's it
guys running around like for some reason
i was like i thought some people do
where's the mask you accept ronin and
spider-man and now daredevil doesn't
even wear a mask that's a hood with a
mask thing he's got a little oh no
you're right no no he's gonna mess it up
right now we're talking about that green
arrow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
brain fart there yeah
so there's like two and and one of them
was unmasked by mysterio so we got one
guy
i i'm so excited and i think okay i like
the character at causey the way they're
flushing them out i thought that uh the
tracksuit mafia bros were were they
they had a great balance that imagined
dragons that sequence in the car was
awesomely visually realized it is from
the comic except it's flipped where
because in the comic it's hawk it's a
clint who's doing the the shooting yeah
and they're in the challenger but i love
the use of him you know like because it
because you don't have your hearing that
messes with your balance a lot and your
sense obvious obviously your sensory
experience um but especially for someone
in his position balance is a big thing
so having to deal with that and the way
they use the auditory perspectives was
so well so well realized i thought this
episode was excellent i don't have a
single problem with it and uh then of
course the tease with um swordsman at
the end see that's the thing is like
we'll go into it just for safety but uh
it doesn't seem like this swordsman is
gonna have the same origin he has at all
right yeah at all but it does seem like
we might have dad fight but they also
they they
they leave it
the way that you can they're like it
could be but it could maybe it doesn't
it it could be this is similar origin or
not we don't know vera could be big bad
he could be a big man either way dad
fight
yeah we don't know
we have no idea this is the most excited
i've been for an episode to episode in a
bit like this is this episode three
really rocked me that was incredible it
was absolutely incredible guys um
yeah yeah wow what are more track suits
next week i got another one thank god
i'm excited
we got to get our track suits bro yeah
bro we got to get a hold of you bro we
got a week bro and i do
the last thing i'll say is in a week the
last thing i'll just get a lot of
traction
i think it's cool because it has been
implemented here from the from the
get-go of hawkeye of clint specifically
not
realizing or being willing to accept the
fact that he is
he is the image that people have of him
he is a hero and this is his journey of
acceptance of that and embracing the
role of being a hero so you know like
the [ __ ] marketing has shown you and
him in the costume which i think is so
stupid that they did that i i i weird as
much as you guys give us crap about
likes are you spoiling stuff um
marketing and like the marketing just
shows you like the poster
boys you show us perhaps he listens to
her yeah maybe there's something coming
because that is a physical indicator
that he will embrace he will embrace
that yeah it also makes sense why they
cut that screen accurate uh comic book
accurate screen costume from the larping
because then they made the joke it
wouldn't make sense there was a guy like
wearing it in the background like uh
kate saw this suit you might like yeah
um excellent stuff guys thanks so much
for being here follow koi on his youtube
channel
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and hey
we will uh catch you guys soon but not
before we shout out some patrons
goddamn differently sane kaz papa patton
levitt odell computers sean don juan
sean john the jedi bro draxon buffy it
works lauren american horse perhaps
you're of native american descent also
works let's get simply faded
peter pacheco
echo i've done that before but echo is
in the show joanna's saying louis
esposito rogue from x-men cree
sj94 never a justin hammer martin rosie
beatty you hot ass lady colin
philip j smith jr starring arnold
schwarzenegger gen 10 smith melanie the
felony leblanc natalie
femfatali doran chase gardner always
getting me harder and ava drazdakova i i
would like to know you thank you guys so
much for being part of our patreon page
and supporting us there you guys mean so
much more to me more than you'll ever
know because you contribute money
and money equals joy
to greggy
[Music]